audi au niger un ex putschiste péri par
le feu de ces hommes trois ans après son
arrivée au pouvoir par un coup d'état
militaire le président ibrahim baré
maïnassara a été tué par ses propres
gardes ce soir les militaires contrôlent
niamey la capitale
son portrait signé eric monier vous même
vous êtes contre ou pour les siens
contre les coups d'état oui parce que
j'estime que et la démocratie y voit
seulement à lui connu comme étant une
vision qui peut être dû inefficaces
comme la personne humaine ainsi parlait
ibrahim baré maïnassara général et
putschistes deux mois à peine après sa
prise de pouvoir par les armes au niger
il ne met pas les coups d'état répétés
t-il
celui d'hier lui a coûté la vie ibm
c'était son surnom a été tué alors qu'il
tentait semble-t-il de quitter le pays
jeudi dans la rue qu'un obus a été tirée
contre le général baré qui fait l'acteur
décédé ainsi qu'une dizaine de personnes
le premier ministre a parlé en disant
que vont ils la situation était de
nouveau calme est anormal que le
gouvernement allait continuer à
travailler son destin politique
ibm se forgent le 27 janvier 1996 le
putsch qui l'organisent met fin à un
blocage politique totale le président
civil et son premier ministre sont alors
empêtré dans une cohabitation l'ofc pour
beaucoup de nigériens
l'armée est le seul recours est pays
occidentaux et notamment la france ne
sont pas loin de penser la même chose
mais ne peuvent le dire ouvertement
alors qu'il prône la démocratie en
afrique
ibm doit passer par les urnes il
abandonne le treillis pour le boubou en
juillet 1996 le voilà président élu et
enfin fréquentable
la france peut poursuivre l'exploitation
de l'uranium nigérien sans en rougir
six mois plus tard une manifestation de
l'opposition tourne à l'émeute et
rappelle que l'élection du bm n'a rien
réglé les problèmes économiques la
question touareg demeure l'armé gronde
et les promesses de démocratisation
restent vaines jusqu'à ces élections
locales de février dernier favorable à
l'opposition est annulé depuis les
rumeurs de coup d'état n'avait pas cessé